let me tell you right now if you're
eating one burger and you can't finish
it and you're a dude
you're a [__]
you're a [__] even if you leave one
bite just like first of all that's just
like plain schoolyard bully yep [__] and
I said it and it's wrong it's not wrong
it's a whole Burger dude come on bro
it's a little bit it's just you care
what are you everyone's Mom I'm not
finished on your plate finish what's on
your plate but like you're not even
really hungry just wait a little bit
till you can eat the whole Burger
because it's just a snack dude after you
eat a burger I go like this what do you
want to eat well you're fat then your
heart Burger in your heart in your soul
you're fat so I ate I got two because I
know my [__] I didn't get fries I got
two burgers okay okay to leave room for
the second Burger I didn't want fries oh
okay yeah so then I sat and I watched a
movie you know what I earned it so [__]
it so I went to go get two I I ordered
two burgers to the house because one
Burger's a snack I don't just eat one I
really don't like that thing that you
say I just really detest it can you tell
me why yeah because it's not even
remotely true you know what I mean
you're not remotely true and people say
them with complete conviction it makes
me mad what do you mean it's not birds
are big fat slob food that you don't
usually even finish and why do I eat too
I think because you're a big fat slob
dude and doing it at like midnight dude